this offense to introduce themselves as
a manual to start perfect sounds great
well my name is Emmanuel Alec Alejandro
hernández so i go by alex my first name
is emmanuel by go by alex and i'm
actually completely new to this dis
polygon community actually can already i
had already been already speak 3 10 4
languages before but i just barely got
really interested in want to learn more
and i just started investigating more on
youtube about about learning languages
and I've been able to find Steve videos
Lucas videos Richards videos and I've
been really inspired to want to learn a
lot more language so as of this moment I
can speak English Spanish catchy it's a
mind I like that's in Guatemala I was
there for two years and I've been
studying Italian for nine months so and
I'm gonna start taking Chinese next
semester's though but I'm really
enthused to be able to use linked
because that's the way I was able to
learn italian i usually ass email
program so i think i definitely think
that's a really viable option to learn
but i'm really i guess the biggest
reason why I'm here today is to be able
to learn a little bit more on how to use
the interface and have some questions
about how you guys have used this this
tool to be able to improve you guys
language learning abilities so but yeah
i'm from x i was born in mexico raise
the United States my family's from
Mexico so I I learned Spanish and
English growing up together and so
that's that's my brief introduction
thank you all right Fernanda hello
everybody I'm Fernanda in Portugal I i
was at initial teacher for more than 35
years and then retired now so I've been
using some of my time creating materials
for link so i have uploaded some
European Portuguese materials and
lessons well I'm perhaps i will try to
learn some spanish and i'd like to to
learn some
that oh I want to learn in an ink well I
I speak some other languages I learned
German many years ago where I think i
forgot almost everything perhaps it's a
way to try to remind those words that I
forgot and I also learned French while
it's me thank you hello everyone my name
is Helen Burgess on link I'm sky blue
teapot i joined link four years ago give
or take to learn russian because i
decided to try and teach myself russian
from the internet and was getting
frustrated and I found link on the
internet and joined and Steve talked me
into being a tutor for english and and i
am now a self-employed efl teacher I
teach mostly Russians and I am learning
French and German and Russian or which
I'm reasonably fluent at now and I'm
learning Japanese which I'm very very
slow at and when i get when japanese no
longer gives me the really bad headaches
i'm going to start on Mandarin Chinese
which Steve assures me is absolutely no
harder than speaking English rare once
you learn once you learn it yes Julie Oh
golly can you hear me now what we do
here jolene can you hear me it's your
turn to make a self introduction okay
well we move on to Keith and then I move
back to gradually okay hi everybody my
name is Keith or on link my name is kay
Kay he'll the EO in my name is for
Esperanto which is one of my
one of my hobbies I came to link about
one year ago to study Swedish and now
I've been 11 months using linq and
really really enjoying the experience
I've had some two or three years of
Evening lessons before before starting
link but I find the link method very
very effective I also study on link
Russian and a little bit of finnish i
live in finland i've been living in
Finland for 10 years i'm originally from
from australia 12 years i think in
finland so I already speak Finnish
language I've studied Russian language
at the University and I've been on
exchange for for one year in st.
Petersburg so I use use use link to
improve through those skills and at
school and Australia studied Indonesian
language though I speak Indonesian
language quite well and using haven't
been using Indonesian on on link but
looking at ways of also using languages
languages that are not supported
directly with link but yeah it's good to
see some familiar or put some faces to
the names on the link system thank you
saying here yeah we have a problem with
yoli you can't hear us surely how she's
typing well we'll move on to Sean and
we'll see we can now resolved if anyone
has any advice for Jolene who all of a
sudden can't hear and you could type
yeah I didn't do any with my microphone
she says I don't know she was able to
hear at the beginning and now she can't
hear Sean over you and then we'll see
what we can do for Jolene her hey I'm
Sean I'm from Atlanta Georgia I've been
using link for about 22 weeks maybe the
most trying to learn German my wife and
I are moving to Switzerland in about
seven or eight months hopefully so
that's my motivation I only speak
English I took French for three years in
high school about six or seven years ago
propel more net
10 years ago now and I don't remember
anything so hopefully have a uh
hopefully I'm better at learning German
that was French oh that's okay no uh if
anyone has any advice for Julian she's
the only one who can't hear she must it
must be something in her setting because
everyone else come here alright what we
will do is will start from the other end
and we'll start with Sean and basically
ask any question you want whether it be
on language learning or link or whatever
you want so we'll go back would go from
left to right and then it's right to
left and in the meantime yeah too bad
about Jolene something must have changed
something I know she spoke earlier and
heard when it's also see kill hears it
don't be mm-hmm just jump in whenever
you hear just jump in so Rachel uh any
questions I guess I guess what I'm
struggling right now is how do you
restart to remember the gender of
various of words I think that's probably
gonna be the most challenging part all
right i'll go i'll provide an initial
answer and because all of us have had
some experience with languages that have
gender others can then comment with
their with their ideas I mean with
regards most languages have some basic
rules governing gender and in some
languages they're very straightforward
like in Spanish just about every route
every now and accept mono that ends in
an always feminine so there are some
rules like that in German there's a list
you know any German book yet I'll tell
you which words are supposed to you know
and it's supposed to be a masculine
feminine or neuter I have to admit that
I can never remember those lists and so
what I find is that with enough exposure
over time as you learn phrases and you
get used to saying things as parts of
phrases because because it's not only in
your
the issue of gender is also the issue of
cases with gender well there's no many
things to learn to remember and I found
when I was learning German that the more
time I spent over the tables I just
couldn't retain that for very long
however when I was speaking more I would
hit it right more more off you know I'd
be hitting it right thirty forty percent
and information you got to say seven set
personally I wasn't able like I still go
over the tables but I think it has a
minimum benefit jolene are you active
again no all my sound quality is a bit
rough all right let me see if i plug in
the this guy here hello is that any
better I hear he just fine Steve ok so
maybe Mike okay ah anyone else want to
comment on the issue of how to remember
the genders I think it can be sold with
lots of practice I'm reading and
listening I don't see any other of
course you can memorize lists of words
but that's a bit tedious I mean it is
easier in Portuguese a lot more
difficult in German because you have
pretty aware i studied German none of I
know if you go to tease yeah I know I
don't want to discount the idea of I'm
looking at the tables and the rules and
and I think you can revisit those rules
from time to time to try and see if it
doesn't help you notice but ultimately
my big thing with language ring is you
have to develop the ability to notice
and so you you should deliberately if
you see a phrase in German where you
know it's feminine and you're reading it
in a magazine underline it just helped
train your brain to notice and hope that
over time you'll develop a break habits
that's about the best that I can offer
any other advice on that scroll
okay I never got the hang of it with
German but with french and russian i
found that they tend to be masculine
unless is a good grammatical reason for
them not to be right so so
overwhelmingly with with with both
languages if you're not sure take a punt
and guess that it'll be a masculine and
you'll be right more often than you roll
drew however the difficulty is even in
French I would say that the more I the
more I speak French the better I get ad
gender even if I know the gender when
you're speaking quickly i don't find i
have the time to think about the gender
I just come up with a sentence and so
even if I know it I don't have time to
deliberately decide that it's going to
be masking it and of course Russian is a
little easier than German because
because it's more regular it seems to me
anyway ok well let's move on Keith the
other question about lake or language um
none really come to mind right now okay
organ on it comment I found the link
system be very very effective I've in
the past used spaced repetition systems
no you have lists of words and you go
through them every day and it's very
very mechanical and I had tremendous
success with that but link sort of
combines the statistics and the numbers
that you get from from a computerized
system and gives you sort of continuous
feedback every day that you've you're
making progress because sometimes when
you're learning a language is difficult
to to measure your own progress and
difficult to get sort of feedback about
how you're going and I find just by
following that the numbers in in link
which is your known words in your linked
words there although they're not
scientific in in any way seeing those
numbers grow and for example seeing your
avatar grow or seeing seeing your lesson
count grow these type of numbers help
encourage you to keep going and keep the
ball rolling so
that's what I that's what I find most
effective from from link thank you i
mean my belief is that the results I
like like this lady I can't remember her
name who was the head of language
instruction at the University our San
Diego State University he once said that
language learning amounts to it depends
on your motivation or your attitude
towards the language at the amount of
time you spend and your ability to
notice and so I'd link we try to measure
your level of activity which is the
number words you've read and I'm
referred to know which is not very
scientific uh okay so yeah you heard
Julian's gonna leave us okay by jolene
sorry she couldn't get her microphone
work so we measure we measure based on
your level of activity and people
sometimes complain well my total known
words count do I really know those words
it doesn't matter I found it to be a
very accurate measurement of my progress
because when it says that I know 30,000
words in check I don't perhaps no 30,000
words in Jack and many of those words
because jack is very inflected many of
those words are in fact different forms
of the same word but I find that I
understand more and more what I'm
reading so it tends to accurately
reflect how well I understand what I'm
reading and listening to but that
extended in fact does measure not only
my level of activity but also my
progress in the language so yeah I
defend our our commitment to the
statistics of known words although a lot
of people wanna question us all right
Helen any questions or comments um i
have found link to be tremendously
useful in keeping your motivation going
pushing you through the plateaus and I I
focus we've had we've had this challenge
this awesome we've had we've had this
challenge going on link and it is a it
is so characteristically link in that
all you've got is a deadline you said
what you're going to actually achieve by
that deadline and it's whatever you feel
is worthwhile and achievable and
what I found is if you set yourself a
challenge no matter what it is it
improves all your all your skills so for
instance I set myself a challenge to
read half a million words in russian not
to understand them not to learn the
words not to write anything about simply
to read them and I have noticed its had
a major effect on all my Russian spec so
I I think there's an awful lot to be
said for just having a goal that you're
moving towards and as steve says a
pointer for activity that he's going up
you don't and another thing that's very
linked about that challenge where I said
it was entirely as an initiative that
came from the members it's not something
that link you know I didn't say let's
have a link challenge I think that was
one of the members suggested doing that
oh I and I must say we all have
different challenges but your point
about goals is is absolutely correct and
that for example in my certain five days
to Quincy challenge where I said I'm
going to go to Prague in a year I'm
going to work as hard as I can so that
when I I get there I hit the ground
running that really helps to motivate
you and as you get closer to the
deadline then you work even harder so
yeah goal setting is very important
fernanda and a comment or question thing
I no particular question no okay and
just there is one thing I haven't figure
out what it is exactly what is the
difference between the the Portuguese
podcasts and the regular lessons you
find in the linked sites okay a podcast
is simply an audio blog basically has
nothing necessarily to do with link or
with language learning and so different
people have podcasts they could be
podcasts on you know what movie stars
are up to on business on
and so forth and we have at link we have
also created some podcasts because the
advantage of a podcast is that it gets
listed in itunes so that if we create
some content in the form of podcast we
can put it up in the iTunes Store and we
hope that that will attract people over
the link but in from the learners
perspective there's no difference a
podcast is just content that has audio
in Texas and so whether it's about
history or economics or science and if
the learner is at a sufficient level to
handle that podcast then it becomes you
know appropriate learning material and
some of our members have particularly
Vera in Germany has been very active she
has actually written to some of these
German podcasters and obtain permission
to use her material a blink and that in
many cases she actually transcribes the
podcast which is a tremendous amount
work but for intermediate and higher
learners this is excellent learning
material and because typically a podcast
doesn't have a transcript for her to
create the transcript is a tremendous
service to our learning community so we
get those in the library an example in
Portugal is that the RTP or tsf Portugal
puts out excellent absolutely excellent
podcast and I have listened to hundreds
of hours of these interviews you know
hislop place well it has nice evo
remember the other ones excellent but
there are no transcripts so if we if we
were and I once wrote them and I said
can we use your material they don't even
answer which is normal most of these
most of these radio stations won't
answer but so that's a podcast I know as
Peter joined us hello I speak yes hi can
you hear me ah very well yes very well
maybe we can interact or Iran I'm a bit
late not a problem maybe you could
briefly introduce yourself and then
we'll continue it with our discussion
yes I'm as Peter from Germany and I'm on
link to learn Chinese I'm learning
Chinese quite a long time and I just
entered again into link I had some
problems with Chinese within a link and
now I want to prepare for Chinese
proficiency test the HSK test and I want
to use link to prepare for this and two
together to a new level in Chinese okay
now let me get ready re well first of
all I should point out that hans peter
is also a major contributor in terms of
french content and chinese hills into
our link library fernanda is a great
contributor starting more recently Helen
has been a contributor very innovative
creative the creator of what was it
called The Adventures of blue burger
something i can't remember mine Michael
truck may contain traces of dodo there
we go okay um so yeah Fernando does that
answer your question about podcasts and
sort of Noah huge yard lyra my forum I
was to move to be talking all the time
okay emmanuelle do you have any comments
questions about language learning
remotely hello a man you Alton Julian is
BEC doline is back although I don't see
her on the screen um ok well let's go
we'll go back to wit hanspeter what we
were doing is I don't know what happened
with the manual maybe uh can you guys
hear me know
okay no okay no good and I novato hello
Sean muted a manual because they had a
lot of background noise but all Sean's
frozen okay all right let's go to
hanspeter we are basically any question
comment about language learning in
general or about Linc anything you would
like to say or ask yes I had my problems
with Chinese but maybe that's not too
what as also interested in that the word
splitting and these problems but I found
now a way to manage this as I try to
make the content in that way that the
words are already splitted and split and
then I think it's it works quite well
and I'm now very happy with the system
wrong at term with French I had quite a
success i were with about 10,000 links
and I I think link was very helpful in
this respect that one can have really
progress with link the obviously you
know we started out doing only English
and then we got I always feel feel that
you know the word the whole world
shouldn't speak English in fact we
should encourage people to learn
languages so then we moved to this
multi-language platform we not have 20
languages obviously link works better
for some languages than others people
complain in German for example where you
have the divided the split verbs that
it's very difficult and there the
solution horses to edit your
and we haven't got the ideal solution
for Japanese and Chinese but at this
point we don't have the resources to
spend on making it better so I mean I
use it for both Japanese and Chinese
it's ninety percent good obviously if
the incoming content as you say is
already split and this is what shigihara
we started doing for his Japanese blog
content then it works fine but there is
this definite this issue of defining
what is a word in both Japanese and
Chinese and we have to go to a certain
algorithm and the algorithm isn't
perfect so there may be solutions out
there we once did approach some the
University of Hong Kong for some they
were working on some some projects and
we tried their thing it didn't work I
mean we have very limited resources and
for us to go and pursue that to really
make it perfect it everything that seems
like not an awful lot of work ends up
being a lot of work and so we basically
stayed away from from that until we get
some other issues settled so I I hear
what you're saying and I wish it were
better for Chinese and Japanese although
I use it and I'm quite happy with it
yeah me too I mean when I three years
ago japanese i found very difficult and
then suddenly this brought in the
automatic worked splitting and an
overnight it was like twice it was like
half the work to use it because i was
like oh i see that's the word and that's
the word and that's the word yeah Kenny
ah i'm not a perfectionist and I but i'm
quite willing to take imperfection in
Jafar's language learners concerned not
in my car but you know there are things
i don't understand the words don't split
quite perfectly all the time there's
stuff i forget none of that bothers me
so but i know there are people who are
more demanding than that and that's all
a matter of our personality so there's
not much we can do Sean you're consuming
them but we can hear you so why don't
you go back to the first off no Emily
all has this phone can we hear a manual
yeah can you guys hear me know
okay your tie resort sorry about that i
was kind of weird i know it was acting
up but anyway so I have a really really
adil um I guess you could say when it
comes language learning right now as of
this moment the biggest thing I'm
struggling with right now is actually
making the decision and the reason I say
that is because I'm so excited about
learning languages that it gets to me to
the point where I want to always learn
another language I'm sure you guys have
all been there and I've been with the
time for about nine months now but when
do you guys know is the point when you
can start learning another language if
that makes any sense like for example
right now I've been studying that
Italian for nine months and I feel
pretty comfortable with it but I really
want to start learning French you know
so like I've I've actually have my ass
email book my French a see my book and
I'm just like okay well I haven't
finished my intermediate to advanced
Italian how do i get to the point where
I can I just study a little bit of
Italian a little bit of a day and then
go back to French I don't I guess my
question is how do you know when is a
point where you can want to another
language or can you learn to it at the
same time who wants to volunteer I we've
got a number of multi language learners
here who wants to volunteer an answer I
could give it a shot there's some
there's a point of diminishing returns
when maybe it's better to switch to a
new a new language and speak more
languages poorly then speak one language
very very well so if you feel if you
feel comfortable in Italian and you're
happy with that with the level by by all
means i would say to take on another one
and as for learning multiple languages
at the same time that's for for for me
everyday everyday life and i don't i
don't seem to have a problem with them i
don't get them mixed up so by all means
with the language learning you were to
keep keep all the languages active some
house i have some club over routine or
or wise to keep your Italian fresh while
you you take on some some new language
but I don't know I certainly have the
same the same problem I if I travel to
some country I get quite excited and
very tempted to start
in a language or if I know I have some
trip coming up I want to I feel like I
want to learn it I have to keep telling
myself no I have enough languages to
work on at the moment then that's it and
I've decided actually won one reason why
I picked up Esperanto is you could you
can never stop learning all the
languages in the world and it's brando
tries to solve so that problem but it's
just a hobby really anywhere else yeah i
agree in fact on i'd give the same
answer to just about anything which is
if you're getting bored do something
different I mean I I learn Russian but
when i get wake up one morning and think
i do not want to do russian any more
than I think ok perhaps it's time for
another language for a bit when i get
bored of that then it's time to go back
to russian or on to yet another language
that's better you can add a number of
languages yes for instance i did a lot
of French in the last years and I was in
France a few weeks ago and afters it I
thought about changing languages again
and doing something different but the
main reason is that i'm planning to go
to Taiwan again and to China and that
motivates me again to do a little bit
more Chinese and not so much French um
yeah I mean the thing about learning
languages is if you go to a buffet and
there's 25 delicious dishes there you
really have to make a choice because if
you ate every single dish should be sick
but with language learning that's not
the case you're not gonna get sick
you're not getting it in digestion from
too many languages but there is a time
constraint so I mean and the more
languages we have the more were torn
because we want to get deeper into the
languages that we already know and then
were motivated
new language and there is no easy answer
I used to say that I could only learn
one language at a time because I get so
involved in that one language it totally
occupies me but most recently you know I
went from Russia to check then I kind of
felt my Russian was suffering so I want
to spend some time on the Russian to
maintain it then I was in Prague report
speaking Czech and having a great time
so i know i said myself i'm going to
learn korean but i find it difficult to
tear myself away from check because i
don't want to lose Brian check and at
the same time i was in berlin for three
days and I felt that my German wasn't
quite as good as i would like to be so I
motivated to do some German there's just
not enough time in the day so what I end
up doing now is I'll get the few
interviews on automatically every day I
will get my interview from Czech radio
one day one or two a day and i'll try to
force myself to do an hour of korean
even though it's always you know you
tend to almost fall in love with the
language that you spent the most time
with and then it's very difficult to
start up with a new language I found
this I found it very difficult to break
away from Russian in order to check once
I got further and further in the check I
liked it more and more but now I find it
difficult to tear myself away from my
Korea from my check in order to go ahead
at Korean and enterprise German is
concerned that was a great idea leaving
Berlin and I since I haven't had time to
do anything I'm German except once a
week I hope to speak to hope to speak to
Reinhardt in Austria we have a an online
discussion so and of course myself that
way to at least have some involvement
with German but it's a very difficult
decision to manual you just have to do
what you feel like doing is having said
that there's no easy it's one of the
disadvantages that comes from having
these interests interest in languages is
that you end up having to having to
always feel that you should be doing
more with languages that you have no
time to spend you know working on mm-hmm
Sean let's go back to you even though
you're frozen in time there yeah sorry
Laurel Eddie am i hurting the multiple
languages
um or anything happens that um at what
point should i be concerned about really
focusing on the grammar rules or
chelating worried by the law and like
you say just learn phrases well you know
this is a point that that is often a
sort of a subject of some controversy
install would be very interesting to
hear from Fernanda for example who is a
teacher and of course now helen is also
a teacher and some people are more
interested in grammar somewhere less I
think it depends on your nature my own
view is that you need an introductory
overview of how the language works and
when Yuri and that's why I find even for
people on link you know it's a good idea
to grab a teach yourself or s email or
one of those just to go through it to
give you an overview of the grammar
without thinking that you're going to
remember the rules because you won't
remember them but it kind of gives you
so don't get frustrated if you can't
remember you can't reproduce and then
kind of revisit that book you know every
couple of months or so have it sitting I
have a little book sitting by the toilet
is it down there I flipped through the
thing and I see some grammar rules ah my
own view is that until you've had enough
exposure to the language these grammar
rules are very difficult to understand
they don't relate to anything that
you're familiar with ah but they it's
not like they have no use they are
helpful in that they make you more
attentive and remember this whole
attentiveness being alert to the
language noticing what's going on is
very important to that extent the
grammar rules help that's my experience
some people can study grammar rules and
to them it's like I don't know reading
an algebra book it is very helpful to
that and and one last comment is where I
do have grammar books like when I don't
have it handy but one of the best
grammar books I got in Russian it just
had the patterns and it's the same in
Chinese when I did Chinese and had a
book I was just so of all the patterns
and so and that's where I thought with
your subliminal learning there
if you had the basic 50 or 80 patterns
of the language just blasting at you
subliminally you know those are the
things that you have to drill into your
into your brain that's my take on it ah
it's you know it's not like we have we
can't ignore grammar or correct usage
it's just a matter of four different
people they have different ways of
achieving you know improving their their
ability to produce and one final thing
is obviously the moon I find the more
you have listened passively to the
language the more likely you are going
to retain these these patterns when you
go to learn that's my take on it will
skip me and we'll go to well I think
everyone has an opinion on this so we'll
go straight across the board will go to
Keith and then he'll announce potato
fernanda and the manual grammar let's
chop this grammar Shawn can you tell
again do what's your level now and join
them is just a beginner and it you're
moving to Germany and eight months is
that right uh I'm moving this what's one
in eight months so I should probably
warning Swiss German but I can't find
any Swiss German things out there so I'm
warning regular German um but yeah I've
been learning about two two and a half
three weeks maybe at most okay what one
thing I find I have very hard trouble
learning any type of grammar tables and
grammar rules so I learn a lot through
through repetition which is just reading
the sampling again and again or
listening to the same thing again and
again and learning the patterns and the
sounds of the language but I think a lot
of basic language courses or the typical
online language courses that teach you
all of the colors and all of the fruits
and all of these things which i use the
soaring the first day when you arrive
and completely useless when you arrive
there in the country on the first day
all right so picking up a phrase book
where you're learning or you know
looking looking for some lessons which
were based on phrases and learning those
phrases which you know that you will
come out of your mouth focus on those
that would be my my advice right um well
maybe I should tell you what I do on my
way back and forth to work
although Steve friends like this I
listened the pimsleur every day so I do
an hour of pimsleur as I walked back and
forth work so I get quite a bit of
listening done and I also I the last two
weeks have been driving myself
absolutely nuts with German music all
day at work I don't understand any of it
but I certainly start picking up you
know I hear new words every you know
it's kind of exciting as I learn more on
linked aya I start figuring out these
songs it's a and the patterns that go
with it so I don't know if that's
helpful or not but that's what I've been
doing oh sorry oh yeah I just say I
agree with the with Steve's approach
that you don't need to work too hard on
the grandma sure and Iceland are spaces
is necessary but learning and listening
and reading and doing what's fun also
seems to be effective for me Ellen after
three years on Japanese on link I have
cracked and bought a grammar book I was
trying to figure out all the grammar
just through reading and listening it to
it but partly because I can't read
Japanese that didn't work entirely i can
now recognize a noun and adjective a
present tense verb a past tense verb and
a few a few other verb tenses and I
think that's the basics I wouldn't worry
too i'm not worried yet about being able
to recognize a gerund I think I worry
about that i'm not entirely sure i can
recognize a gerund in english but i
think being able to say okay here's a
sentence there's the verb there's a
subject is the object that's an adverb
and and and that's an adjective which is
describing that now is is probably it's
probably a working minimum and the
Japanese I'd like to say some very nice
podcast somebody has actually thought
this through and done some beginners
podcasts that are things like I eat
[ __ ] I am eating chocolate I have eaten
chocolate I want to eat chocolate I have
to eat chocolate and that's brilliant
and that's the patterns and though that
that course the the the chocolate course
I've listened it over and over and and I
wish that were there fought for every
language just just the patterns the same
sentence how many different tenses can
we put this sentence in okay I'm better
when I'm reading link or from books and
I find an interesting sentence I I try
to extract the sentence if it has a
special grammatical pattern and then I
repeat this within an key or other
spaced repetition program and then try
to bring this more into my brain than
just reading and listening especially
also in Chinese and I try to do this
because this it's sometimes very
difficult for me to remember special
words or special patterns and I find it
very good to extract sentences and in
Chinese I do it with audios always and
to repeat these even more orphans and
the texts okay fernanda from your
experience in teaching Portuguese which
has a lot of special characteristics
that are different from Spanish French
and so far as verbs are concerned where
I from the perspective of a teacher and
a learner how do you deal with graham
well I don't have a recent experience in
learning languages now I mean for
several months I keep telling myself I
want to learn Spanish but I haven't
started it seriously
but when i learned language and i was a
student and I learned the grammar a lot
and i i i i was learning the three
language at the same time i was learning
English French and German and I studied
grammar a lot so perhaps because I was a
teacher I think grammar is important
because I want to find an explanation
why why why is this pattern like this I
want to understand the patterns and the
rules of the language for me it is
important that I understand that other
people can learn in different ways ya
know I think it's very much a matter of
individual personality emmanuelle or it
sorry now you told us at the beginning
that you'd Alex Alex it's okay don't
tell us um yeah actually when I was in
Guatemala I actually when I learned this
this my entire catchy we had a grammar
book sorry about that we had a grammar
book and I had learned the ins and outs
of the language that's how I was able to
learn that language was just kind of
discouraging but when I learned Italian
and I use this assuming both it was a
completely different story this time
around as far as the way I learned I
went about learning I just recently met
not recently maybe two months ago bought
a grammar book but I was able to express
myself around you know pretty well the
first couple three months then four
months I was pretty Trish myself really
well in six months and then finally I
bought a grammar book and I was like oh
that's why I say like this that's why
this is like this so it all depends on
the individual preference that I agree
with everybody else in that aspect as
far as if you want to know the grammar
rules but for me personally I just want
to be able to talk to people you know
I'm not going to be a italian language
professor but i want to be able to say
the things that i want to say to other
people you know and with grammar i do
feel that it's important to some point
but only to where you can be understood
by other people if there's something
that you don't understand why it's like
this then look it up that's where
you can take the initiative to look that
that part up or I don't how to explain
really well but but yeah it's all up to
the individual preference I agree with
everybody else here but my personal
preference is to completely just immerse
yourself in language as far as listening
and and talking I think that that's
definitely the best way to do it and
then afterwards comes grammar as far as
being able to enjoy the language the
language learning process okay yeah I
think we're all saying the same it
depends to some extent on your goals
depends on what you like to do and and
this John says or was a Keith said you
know it's very important that we enjoy
the whole process because that means it
will stay with it and ultimately if we
stay with it will succeed insofar as
German Jonas take a shine if you have
seven months you should can definitely
get yourself to a level where you will
understand most of what people say and
you'll be able to express yourself
someone you know awkwardly but once
there the more you use the language
you're the better you'll get of
expressing yourself I have I mean my son
Mark lived and he live desert for two
years I've been to Switzerland I mean
standard German is very much huge there
even though monks themselves and I Haiti
hans-peter or someone else has more
experience on on the you know Swiss
German versus standard German in
Switzerland but it's very much an
advantage to be able to speak standard
German even though they may all speak
English or may not or they speak Swiss
German amongst themselves it's a big
advantage to learn German and there's no
question that you can get there and I
right all right yeah I'm thinking
positively so yeah and as phaidor have
you had any experience in being in
Switzerland then to the extent to which
standard German is used there it's even
sometimes difficult for Germans to be in
Switzerland and to understand the people
so but most people of course be quite
good German but sometimes you may meet
some people from the mountains or from
tiny villages they speak not so clear
gem they speak local dialects and that
can be a problem but the the newspapers
are in standard German radio of coach
here is a being in an environment that's
gonna help you get better and better
you'll find it you know you can very
much you know improve so get turning my
advice is to get my strategy would be to
get my comprehension up to a level where
I hit the ground running I understand
what people are saying and then you'll
find it you'll improve your spoken
German pretty quickly you have that face
behind interesting yeah any other any
questions you know we shouldn't go on
forever you probably could go on forever
we should probably try and make it a one
hour hang out so we've got five more
minutes any other questions about
language learning or link in particular
I it can ask a question kind of yell out
link I'm not I guess I just started
using Lync a couple actually maybe a
week ago a couple days ago I'm not
complete sure but I really like the
structure the way it's set how how does
it how does link um work exactly i guess
you could say i know i've seen the
little introductions everything but just
in general is there a way to find other
people and chat on there i mean i know
that in general the way it's structured
up is structured is amazing as far as
just having the the text and then be
able to listen to it in and then but
what is i guess my question is what is
linked all about exactly like are you
able to link words i'm not very
completely i will give a brief a brief
sort of explanation a lot of people
actually have trouble they come to link
and they're looking for a more
conventional form of language learning
and and it isn't there and they're
confused essentially link is built
around the idea that if you can build up
your vocabulary if you can build up your
comprehension and your familiarity with
the language a lot of other things will
become easier so link is not like the
only place where you go to learn
because people inevitably are going to
buy a little book they might have people
they talk to they might be doing
pimsleur it doesn't matter but link is a
resource where you find audio and text
always for every audio lesson and there
is a transcript so probably link is the
largest repository of audio and text
content / difficulty level across 20
languages that you're going to find on
the internet and it gets that way
because the members contribute they
either create something themselves or
they find copyright free material or
they obtained permission from other
people who are creating content to share
it on link and even if it's under
copyright you can bring it in and use it
with link for your own in your own
personal account even though you can't
share it in the library and so the
fundamental activities in link are to
listen and read and then to save words
and phrases to a personal database that
you can then regularly review and you
can review them as lists you can review
them in flash cards close test or in my
own case I tend to review them most
often in the text that I'm reading
because once you have saved a word or
phrase it's highlighted in yellow and
because I read so much it's like Helen
like I read hundreds and thousands of
words link and I listen to that that
i'll just see these yellow links over
and over and over again and that gives
me the kind of repetition that I need we
have new insofar as the grammar is
concerned there are so many grammar
resources out there including on the web
you can attach grammar explanations to
your saved link you can have like if
it's a French you can have loopholes you
got to her which is a conjugating
dictionary so you can look up the
conjugations the words there are similar
resources for German so that if you save
a word you can look up a gram resorts
and put that in the notes to that link
there are examples there that you can
also drill down to the way the original
text was located I mean there's a lot of
functionalities it's hard to explain
that I should probably do another
session on link where i share my screen
and show people exactly what i do how i
navigate the library how i use the vocab
page how r use the best in patients over
with a few minutes remaining here is
difficult to do that but yeah the basic
idea of link is that it's a resource
it's a community it's it's one part of
the language learning process it has a
lot of the pieces there people you can
link up to native speakers I mean
certainly the people that I spoken to
ask oprah's Fernanda and Portuguese
exposed to having spoken handsome I
think with hans-peter we did speak in
German ones certainly with yevgeni and
Selena wonderful tutors Russian yarda
Dan yak in check it's a wonderful
community and it's a process so I think
with the amount of time available that's
but all I can say at this point thank
you any other questions yes I have a
question our flash cards and the other
exercises provided created by the system
where are the users or the people who
upload lessons to create them the flash
cards are based on whatever list you
want to study so if you're studying a
lesson typically on the right hand side
you'll see a list of all the words that
you have saved from that lesson and in
20 30 50 words if you choose to flash
card or close test or do dictation it'll
go after those words if you go to if you
have our tagging words say you're
tagging words for like I'll tag words
for case endings and Russian or verbs of
motion or I'll tag for example you know
conjunctions which are so useful in a
language you know or phrases that help
you move from one thought to another
i'll i'll tag these handy phrases so
then i go to the vocab section and i'll
click on that tag name which brings up
125 or however many words and that's the
list that then will be part of the flash
cards so you the learner decide what you
want to be in the flashcards and
system automatically creates the
flashcard supposed test so they are
created by the system ok yeah ok yeah
now there are some other questions here
um double final FMS media I will contact
you Helen on how to locate a chemistry
interviews it's a phenomenal resource
every day ten interviews with transcript
I know you've told me several times and
but I think now I'm finally good enough
that I can actually listen to what
you're listening to and understand it
it's taken me a bit longer it's a
phenomenal resource it sits there they
have a certain perspective political
perspective but they have the interview
international leaders on there as well
they interview members of the Duma but a
lot of their own commentary is very
critical of the government so it's very
much a dissident radio station own fifty
percent by gas prom which is very
difficult to understand however okay
Sean says I sent to upload copyrighted
material so how do you guys primarily
move words to status for known okay how
do I move status no different people to
different things and you can move them
to known by flash cardi because there is
and I don't remember quite how it works
but if you get it right twice in a row
it'll look up one status you can go to
vocab and there you can move you can
look at a hundred words and decided you
want to move them all up one level in
status if you want or two levels I
personally I don't do much of that and I
don't know how my words end up is known
but they do because I've got more and
more known words so I don't know
different people different things I'll
some time to go in and do a bunch of
words and just move them all up to one
status or move them to know sometimes I
flash card on my iPhone iPad i'm often
moving stuff up to known there but i'm a
sort of a sporadic flash Carter there
are people who are more systematic and
because I know that because people
comment and so yeah how do others move
their data where's the status at all any
comments I
is is flashcards often on the iphone
application if I'm wedding a queue or
something i'll go through and mark the
words i don't normally say yes or no I
go and just update the status
immediately because often i'm updating a
word to just making it known and then
when i'm doing a lesson after I've
finished a lesson I'll go through the
words in that lesson and mark all the
words which I knew as known so use a
matter of both techniques and sometimes
if i'm reviewing a lesson later and i
notice one word which is yellow and
should be should be white then i'll
click or blue I can't remember the
colors click on that and market is known
so you get the hang of it after a while
you get there you'll get to feel for how
it works and there's no great damage
everybody Flint something words to known
because I'll often find words that show
up is known that I don't know any longer
or don't be oh I'm not sure about the
energy that the status back to two or
three do you feel concerned we don't see
it in it like i have i've run into a
couple of war finally know like 250
words so it's it doesn't happen very
often but the yeah i find a word that
was mark is known and then i'm reading a
passage I'm like well I don't know this
anymore should I be concerned about that
or hallmark the two and carry on doesn't
matter at all all that matters is what
you're going to be able to understand
and do in the language six months from
now and words regularly I might have
missed it maybe I moved all my words to
known and I missed three words in fact
that I don't know so they actually show
up as white words because yeah anything
that you moved to status for is
underlined right so that that's a word
that you've met before like sometimes
you see a word underline you don't even
remember having met this brand before
that's how much you've forgotten it so
you open up moving back to two but there
are also words that you inadvertently
skipped and you move them all to known
in this white and you come across it
less regularly I'll save a word that's
quite that I no longer know what it
means even if I do some other that it
doesn't matter it's it's the whole
process of
the biggest thing the most important
thing is the fact that you are exposing
yourself to the language and you are
listening and reading and getting
through this meaning of the text and
hopefully you're enjoying and finding
this text interesting and so you're just
continuing to eat up and have Mercia
soften more and more content and the
brain is just getting used to more and
more of the language and so yeah the odd
word that shows up is known that you
don't know it's really a non-event the
overall overall over a sufficient period
of time is accurate but individually
with individual words and a given point
in time it could be out okay any other
comments okay i recommend signing up for
the link of the day link of the day
males where you get a list of all the
words to review on that day and that
list includes level for words and those
words that then gives you a chance to
check that do you really do you really
know them you can put them down down a
level or down to one if somehow work at
level four and you use some haven't got
it right right yeah I mean that's true
here and the advantage of course with
those links of the days that you can
also review them on your portable device
which is a great place to do it while
waiting for the you know until someone
that you're waiting in line at the
grocery store and then people get angry
because you didn't keep moving in line
or something all right well should we
close it off there and we'll try and do
this again and maybe next time we'll try
and focus in on some specific subjects
and I thank you very much for
participating and I look forward to
meeting you all online again and I think
this google plus technology by March was
pretty successful except for poor
Angeline okay great i can decide on
achievement by my mind you all right